[Musique]
bonsoir mes petits amis hausse
hu
accro mais oui mot chronos descendent
vite leur montrer ton beau livre et moi
je leur raconte la suite des aventures
de notre petite amie cornichons pour le
chemin propos pompom les parents de
cornichons continue à chercher partout
leur petit garçon
vont-ils le retrouver vous allez le
savoir très bientôt tu es prêt nounours
à luzy pas trop nous sommes la maman de
cornichons qui est très triste vent de
la laine noire
son papa qui est très triste aussi ne
joue plus de la guitare les pauvres mais
continue quand même à le chercher plutôt
beau il voyage beaucoup et ils
s'arrêtent souvent pour demander à
toutes les personnes qu'il rencontre
s'ils n'ont pas vu leur fils et les
voilà arrivés dans un petit village un
jour de marché
dada regarde tous les petits enfants qui
sont venus l'admirer mais cornichons
n'est pas là il ne se trouve pas parmi
le pauvre daf qu'il doit être triste
pauvre pomme et tout à coup dada prend
une grande décision
puisque mon petit ami n'est pas là je
vais aller le chercher moi tout seul et
je sens que je vais le retrouver et le
voilà qui part ou grand galop en
direction de la grande forêt vas-y tu
adores et il galope et ils galopent
cornichons et son ami bûcherons sont en
train de pousser leur charrette pleine
de bois quand ils entendent dada qui
arrive à toute vitesse à leur rencontre
dada c'est mon dada cris cornichons qui
s'accrochent au cou de son ami bout de
temps bravo da
bravo dada dit le bûcheron dada est
tellement heureux qui tire la charrette
sur laquelle est monté le bûcheron
tandis que cornichons à califourchon sur
le dos du cheval crise
il arrive à la roulotte
le papa et la maman de cornichons sont
si heureux de retrouver leur fils qu'ils
en pleurs de joie
tony des cornichons donne à sa maman la
bouteille en verre de venise avec les
perles le collier de coquillages
la pièce en or la pierre de lune les
agat et labels améthyste qu'il a gardé
précieusement pour elle
et le soir les parents donnent une
grande fête dans leur roulotte tous les
amis de cornichons sont venus ils
s'écoutent le pape à jouer de la guitare
et le petit garçon très heureux s'endort
dans les bras de sa maman
allons les enfants l'histoire est finie
nous allons nous coucher 18 news
voilà ce qu'ils sont gentils comme une
nuit bonne nuit les petits la jette à la
lumière hatton
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonne nuit petit nicolas bonne nuit
petites tapes renel bonne nuit tous les
enfants embrasser bien fort vos parents
allez vite vous coucher mais auparavant
n'oubliez pas de faire votre toilette et
de bien vous l'a vu le ton et fait beau
rêve pneus
[Musique]
e
oh
[Musique]